paul boyer is an arizona state senator
who originally was supportive of the
arizona recount of the 2020 election
which we recently discussed which is
looking at things like
bamboo fibers on ballots in maricopa
county paul boyer was supportive of that
originally and that very same state
senator now says
he regrets his support of that movement
and that it quote
makes us look like idiots it's
i guess like a moment of clarity in a
sea of absurdity
in arizona and of course he's absolutely
correct but really only at the micro
level and what i mean by that is that
yes the individuals who supported this
nonsense and i mean
josh hawley in the u.s senate people
like paul boyer in the arizona state
senate the whole lot of them
they do look like idiots he's right
about that
but the problem is that we as a country
look like idiots internationally
globally
because of these people now the full
quote from senator paul boyer
is it makes us look like idiots i didn't
think it would be this ridiculous
it's embarrassing to be a state senator
at this point now it's all great
paul boyer came to realize this he's now
saying it's a bad idea
okay but you can't simply disown
the entire movement that you started
simply
because it imploded in shame and what i
mean by that is
that paul boyer is reacting to the
outcome of this movement
imagine if somehow i mean it would have
been a tragedy nationally but imagine if
they had found a way
a bogus way to change the outcome of a
state where they figured out a way wow
even though biden won arizona
they figure out some way to flip it to
donald trump or imagine if they had been
able to do it in enough states
to actually flip the election from joe
biden to donald trump
he wouldn't be saying that we looked
like idiots he'd be saying we did
something heroic
even though the truth in either case
is that joe biden won and being able to
flip the results or even trying to do so
is a trash garbage movement
he's trying to disown it now because it
failed
and because it didn't go anywhere and
because it's become
this national and global laughing stock
and so he wants to wash his hands of it
now
because it failed to achieve excuse me
what he wanted it to achieve at least
initially
and at some point they need to accept
that they are number one wrong on the
facts
and number two they are idiots because
they fell for it it's not just
we ended up looking like idiots
and what's unsaid is in part because
this failed to do anything
it was idiotic to fall for this from the
beginning
and you know looking at bamboo fibers
yet another conspiracy theory so the
point here
is great it's always great
when someone realizes the error of their
ways or of their beliefs
and they come to correct that that's one
of the reasons why
science as a process is so valuable
because it contains an error correcting
mechanism and
fixing mistakes or finding that someone
uh
did something wrong believed something
wrong it's rewarded
in science at least it should be when
things go correctly
but it's not you're instantly
rehabilitated
because one time much too late 170
of republicans still believe to this day
that donald trump actually won the
election and joe biden is not the
legitimate president
now you say oh we look like idiots oh
great wow you're back
you're great you're great now you
stumbled into a fact among a sea of
trash propaganda
and now you want a cookie and this is
you know it's it's
it's an important analysis also in the
context of the liz cheney thing
the republican party are a bunch of
hypocrites when they say they're against
cancelling people
and liz cheney says hey guys trump lost
and what he's doing is dangerous and
what he did is dangerous you're canceled
yes they're hypocrites
liz cheney is correct that we have a
process and the process worked and we
had an election and we know the results
she's right about that that's it she
doesn't become a progressive hero
she is not on the left we disagree about
just about everything
and that's an important thing to
remember when we look at these maya
culpas and we look at these
uh i mean not a term i use but come to
jesus moments
do something now to deal with the
systemic fiasco
that you as a part of the republican
party this applies to state senator paul
boyer
it applies to liz cheney it applies to
all of them do something that deals with
the systemic issues
and then maybe i would find myself
having more praise for you